I want to come back to you cuz I I was
asking you questions about the whole
masculine feminine and like the softer
dudes that you're dealing with in
California and I think where we started
to lose your audio you're you're talking
about guys that are sort of on your page
like honest uh good communicator and you
said um good with their hands like they
have to be able to build something sort
of thing so I was asking you like do you
deal with you know situations where like
flat tires you can change a flat tire
you clean out the gutters with leaves
like are these all things that you
typically do yes yeah I
could myself right okay so I mean you
want a guy that obviously takes on the
blue jobs then that takes on more of the
masculine role but you're not finding
that a lot with guys like are they just
not taught those skills in California or
is it just that men are sort of being
like let down with with um culture and
Society
there um I don't know maybe it's just
who I come across you know I I'm sure
they there are some out here but as far
as like
where that's you know that's the
question I know strong men are out there
for a fact cuz I know several guys out
there that are like I know MMA fighters
that could you know like rearrange
somebody's face in two seconds if they
wanted to like like like strong tough
guys like I know guys like that out
there so they do exist it's not like
every dude in California is wearing
skinny jeans and a man bun sort of thing
and at the male feminist you know
parades there's there's some stronger
guys out there you just not finding as
many as you'd expect is what you're
saying
exactly yeah they're just harder to come
across I guess do you my my fault as
well being in you know my stage maybe
there I mean I just find that there
there's a lot that are intimidated you
know when it comes to someone like me
that
has everything already so you're finding
guys are intimidated by you
why do you think they get intimidated by
you um because you know I um already
well established with my you know career
with my have you know my own house my
own I and I can do
everything myself which is
which would which why I would assume
that you know do you think that that
like the strength that you hold out
there or the intim or the
intimidation is part of the problem
could be I would say so how do you not
intimidate a guy um honestly that's
that's a question I'm still trying to uh
answer
myself uh not be
so not
be myself I
guess well well what part of yourself do
you think is intimidating
them um because you can't be anybody
else right yeah yeah exactly
so I don't know that's a great question
how do you think that I would do that
like well I mean you did say earlier on
um you know you're talking a lot about
the um about your successes um I don't
need a man if it happens it happens sort
of thing and I think that one of the
problems that women sort of stumble
themselves into is they sort of navigate
through life is they'll spend a part of
their earlier years especially in their
20s kind of exploring partying dating um
you know seeing what's out there sizing
everything up um while chasing the
career and climbing the corporate ladder
and getting the accomplishments and the
awards and the Retreats and all that
sort of stuff
um and they kind of mold themselves
into a guide some respects like one of
the things that will here often is well
I bring a lot to the table you know I've
got a career I own a house I've got my
life squared away I've got my
investments I drive a Tesla you know we
hear this like over and over again right
do you drive a Tesla is that why you're
smiling no okay I just thought that was
funny because it's that's that's what
you find out here in California right
yeah so it's like it's pretty common
that you know gals will work themselves
in a position where they're like hey you
know I'm this I'm this you know
successful thing and if it happens it
happens s of thing and then they run
into their 30s and eventually their 40s
and they realize well that's not what
guys want and that's not what I wanted
and here I am now kind of you know
pretty close to my expiry date right or
you're getting close to your expiry date
anyway um so I think if you're holding
yourself out there publicly and you know
strong independent woman I noticed on
you know your Instagram like you're
pretty feminine you know in the way that
you hold yourself out but you're also
running a business that looks like
jealous shots or something like that is
that something you do on the side yeah
yeah I do that as well what's that you
do that for parties or yeah yeah mainly
for parties you
know whoever wants jello shots I I make
really like I make a great mixture so
they're kind of
like silent deadly kind of killers um
because they taste so good they don't
taste like alcohol so it's
I yeah so it's just something I did for
fun and it's actually done pretty pretty
well so is that a side hustle that like
earns you some money so you get some
jobs yeah yeah it's not you know not a
lot just it's mainly just to do
something outside of you know what I
normally
do okay I think what's what's
interesting and I wonder Brandy what you
think about this and Rachel obviously
chiming chime in as well I think we hear
it's common to hear things like I'm a
go-getter when it comes to my business
I'm very intentional about making money
or chasing the degree or getting the
professional
designation but when it comes to guys in
a relationship and a marriage and kids
it's very often well whatever is meant
to be will me be meant to be whatever's
going to happen is what's going to
happen and I kind of find it interesting
and I'm curious as
to why why not just be as intentional
with your dating life if you're goal is
to be married and have children as as
you would be with like a business and
making money and things like that what
is there some sort of taboo nature is
there some sort of you
know I'm I'm frowned upon or I'm shamed
by other people for doing anything in
order to get a man I mean I have my own
opinions on it but I'm curious what the
two of you
think um well um I was just thinking
about about what she said earlier about
like well what what do I do because like
um her work is a big part about her um
but whenever it comes to dating it's not
like women can own businesses and be
very like um intentional and care a lot
about that and put a lot of work into
that but when it comes to a relationship
if you put that first and make that your
identity you're just going to attract
the wrong type of men um the kind of men
that like want that want someone that's
more equal to them rather than being not
it's not that you can't be those things
but if you I've seen with like friends
and people close to me when they lead
with those things they end up attracting
um someone that they don't exactly want
and then they Wonder like why they keep
attracting them what does that guy look
like that they don't
want um kind of what she mentioned
earlier just more on the feminine side
just more for me it's someone who's more
um not as ambitious not like very good
with settling um and doesn't really
fully understand like the pink jobs the
blue jobs and the role that a woman can
bring to your life that doesn't include
her having a business and things like
that I think what what MF said earlier
about um like why is it a taboo thing
like is that why women don't want to
leave with their desires of of family
and sometimes I I think that that way
too because if I were to meet a guy and
tell him what I what I really want and
it's to be stay at home mom and put my
husband and my kids first if a lot of
people these days think like oh you just
don't want to work like you just
everyone has kids like everyone has kids
so why would you why would you not want
to work and so that just tells me that
they don't value like what it is that a
woman can bring to your life that's then
it makes you feel like you have to have
some sort of career to be like socially
accepted but isn't that what society's
told men and women for decades now you
know woman needs a man like a fish needs
a bicycle you should climb the corporate
Lou or make money you know you don't
need no man if he shows up he shows up
sort of
thing is that I mean like have have
women been lied
to um I'm not sure who even started that
idea to be to where it's even started
because I think men and women work best
together and they offer different things
so I'm not I'm not sure why that's
happened I can tell you that I grew up
in a single parent household and I
watched my mom do it all and she Prides
herself to this day that she did it all
and she has not had a relationship in
many years and I she struggles to find
someone that like wants to be with or
that she wants to be with and I've I've
lived on that side of a woman that can
do it all and there's no trophy for that
like there there's no there's nothing
that you get out of that like you you
can it's happiness is a choice yes but
there's there's nothing that like that's
not something to be prideful of I'm I'm
proud of her that she did that but I I I
wish that wasn't the case I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out